4 jours et demi après le drame beaucoup
de monde était venu rendre un dernier
hommage aux victimes de l'accident de la
route survenue samedi vers 23h à montsen
en sonéloire Fanny Borius vous avez
assisté aux cérémonies toutes deux se
sont déroulé au creusau
oui clair deux cérémonies qui se sont
passées à quelques centaines de mètres
he de de distance la première ici à
l'église Saint-Eugène où je me trouve il
y avait tout à l'heure près de 500
personnes rassemblées euh pour dire un
dernier revoir à Hugo clémence et
Clément une cérémonie pleine de
recueillement d'émotions loin des
caméras comme l'avait souhaité les
familles pendant près d'une heure et
demi d'abord devant l'église les proches
des victimes se sont succédés pour dire
quelques mots d'amour et d'au revoir à à
leurs enfants leurs frères leurs sœurs
ou leurs amis une cérémonie qui s'est
ensuite poursuivie à l'intérieur de
l'église où et bien là tout le monde n'a
pas pu entrer et il était 5h moin le
quart tout à l'heure lorsque les trois
cercueils ont quitté l'église pour pour
rejoindre le cimetière de Monsen au même
moment une autre cérémonie avait lieu au
pompes funèbre du croau pour caled Medy
et fredge les trois amis qui sont
également déc décédé dans l'accident de
saminti dernier une cérémonie là encore
loin des caméras mais nous avons pu
constater là encore une foule importante
des centaines de personnes qui sont
venus rendre un dernier hommage aux
trois amis les trois cercueil sont
partis tout à l'heure pour la ville de
Lyon et ils doivent décoller demain pour
la Tunisie où les trois amis sont
inhumés euh leur le 4e blessé dans
l'accident Riyad est lui toujours
hospitalisé dans un état grave Fanny
concernant maintenant les circonstances
de l'accident le procureur de la
République a donné quelques éléments de
l'enquête
aujourd'hui oui on commence à connaître
un petit peu le scénario de cet accident
ce que l'on sait c'est que l'alcool
n'est pas à l'origine de l'accident la
vitesse non plus puisque les deux
voitures respectaient la limitation de
vitesse qui est de 90 km/h à l'endroit
de l'accident par contre ce que le
l'enquête dit c'est que l'une des
voitures s'est déportée sur l'autre voie
et a percuté donc la voiture qui
arrivait en face on ne sait pas pourquoi
cette voiture s'est déportée l'enquête
doit le déterminer elle se poursuit
merci Fanny Borius pour toutes ces
précisions